Michael McCarty Brabham Lurie we are
taking a look at
Just Cause three's newest DLC coming out
soon sky fortress and you got to play it
yeah and as you can see it pretty much
just makes you into a flying automaton
fighter jet in every sense the word it's
seijin yeah it it was a power fantasy
before now it's just on a different
level yeah these guys are square enix
they don't seem to care anymore do they
no they're fully embracing how
ridiculous Just Cause 3 is and it it
looks ridiculous judging by how you're
doing strafing around you have a machine
gun on one shoulder and missile launch
around the other you have boost you're
pretty much don't ever have to touch the
ground if you don't want to there are a
few aspects to this DLC this is the
first of three
it's the app you know focus on aerial
combat and strafing runs and you know -
you can have a Dodge and whatnot but the
wingsuit is pretty much just making you
extremely powerful now you are just
destroying entire bases yeah bad you fly
by and give these bombing runs awesome
cool so yeah it looks like over there in
the distance it's like a the equivalent
to the Helicarrier and Avengers I guess
right yeah and that's not part of the
skybox that's one that's the area where
like the Eden Corporation is setting up
I don't know too much about this story
Square Enix didn't show me Square Enix
and Avalanche but apparently the Eden
Corporation is coming in trying to get
in on the Bavarian trade which is that
substance from the base game that people
might remember is kind of giving all
these powerful weapons and tanks but you
can fly to that that Helicarrier from
anywhere it's not it's not a skybox and
it's another two outpost so this one
we're shooting it now is pretty much its
own thing and you know you remember you
destroy them to liberate them there are
two the bow section of the ship and the
stern and actually pretty tough from my
plate as you can see there are a lot of
drones kind of in the sky and
anti-aircraft guns those platforms
floating around it our drone dispensers
so you know there's kind of a strategy
to taking those out first before you
take out the power supplies and the
anti-aircraft
turrets and these satellite dishes as
you come up here and pretty much just
float indefinitely you use your boosts
you have a handbrake that helps a lot
and Eve aid cool a few times i dodge the
missile and then it continued on to
destroy something that I know reel
landing and shooting anyway yeah oh
that's cool yeah awesome alright so
here's the challenge is where these
challenge is actually called wingsuit uh
yeah they're just waiting see challenges
but now they're just a little tougher
because you can boost and boosting is
almost as important as the handbrake
you'll see up ahead you get into the
rafters of the ship and then you have to
in order to get those perfect you really
have to get it down pat as far as when
you're gonna slow down and turn on a
dime and when you're just gonna go for
it and boo straight ahead yeah do you
have any any idea when this is being
released Mike so right now they have a
general time frame of March and that is
the first of the three I mentioned the
land-based DLC will give you just this
giant floating hover mech and that'll be
about two months after the air based one
and then the third which is the sea
based one they're kind of saying it's
like they're calling it the sea heist
it's like an Ocean's eleven on yachts
and barges and whatnot that's gonna be
two months after the second one and
there's not a lot of information about
the story for any of them I wasn't able
to check out the story for the first one
but you know knowing just got three it's
probably just gonna serve as a framework
for you blowing everything up definitely
cool man well thanks so much for walking
us through that little bit there thanks
for having me cool take her